[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 2 n cat et vous
avez raison bienvenue dans votre journal
de l'afrique à la une ce soir le 50e
anniversaire de l'unité camerounaise
l'unification entre la zone anglophone
et francophone une unité au goût amer
depuis cinq ans le pays traverse une
crise majeure entre les deux zones un
conflit qui a déjà fait plus de 3000
morts
l'inflation n'épargne pas l'afrique nous
irons au gabon ou face à l'envolée des
prix une ong locale propose de former
des jeunes à travailler la terre pour
combler la carence en main d'oeuvre
d'une agriculture abandonnés par l'état
au profit du secteur minier du pétrole
reportage à suivre dans cette édition
est notre invité de ce soir est un
artiste camerounais aux multiples
talents musicien accompli chanteur
auteur compositeur producteur guitariste
et percussionniste
il est aussi artiste il présente sa
carte blanche comme musée du quai branly
à paris concerts installations
conférences et créations inédites blick
bassy et dans le journal de l'afrique
le 20 mai 1972 le cameroun fêtait son
unité recouvrer après un référendum qui
donna naissance à la république unie du
cameroun 50 ans plus tard cette date
résonne bien différemment dans la partie
anglophone du pays en conflit avec le
pouvoir central depuis cinq ans des
affrontements qui ont entraîné la mort
de plus de 3000 personnes la
correspondance de mars l amoco depuis
yaoundé
le 20 mai une date symbolique pour les
camerounais depuis 1972 des camerounais
qui chaque année célèbrent leur fête de
l'unité nationale mais une date qui
désormais divise à cause notamment du
conflit qui déchire les deux régions
anglophones du nord-ouest et du
sud-ouest du cameroun depuis octobre
2016 d'une crise identitaire au départ
certains anglophones se disant
marginalisés elle a pris une tournure
militaire depuis octobre 2010 est sur
fond de revendications sécessionnistes
ce 20 mai 2022 marque donc le
cinquantenaire de l'unité nationale
camerounaise une célébration marquée par
le retour d'un défilé civil et militaire
ici à yaoundé sur le boulevard du 20 mai
présidé par le président camerounais
paul biya défilé qui faisait son retour
après deux années d'interruption liée à
la crise sanitaire du coc vite 19 des
célébrations au plutôt sobre qui n'ont
pas fait oublier que le pays est déchiré
par un conflit dans ces deux régions
anglophones et du sud-est où les
séparatistes armés auraient d'ailleurs
lancé un mot d'ordre de boycott je
rappelle que ce conflit qui déchire ces
deux régions anglophones du nord-est et
du sud ouest depuis plus de cinq ans
maintenant a déjà fait au moins 3000
morts et plus de 500 mille réfugiés et
déplacés internes selon des ong locales
et internationales
après la pandémie les conséquences de la
guerre en ukraine qui mine l'économie
mondiale le gabon qu importe 60% ses
produits de première nécessité ne déroge
pas à la règle résultat les prix
s'envolent pour y remédier une ong
proposent de former des jeunes
entrepreneurs agricoles objectif combler
la carence en main d'oeuvre d'une
abandonné par l'état au profit du
secteur minier du pétrole reportage
d'ismaël obiang et alain bakhita et
soraya bakary
armé de son carnet ibrahim boulou fait
le tour des rayons de ce magasin un
contrôle de prix inopinés menés par ce
défenseur des consommateurs gabonais
cependant rien ne lui échappe farine
huile sucre lait chaque hausse des prix
est noté une inflation record sur les
produits importés qui s'est accélérée
avec la guerre en ukraine donc le blues
comme vous le savez est importé de
l'ukraine il ya aussi les zulos ils sont
importés de l'ue qu'elle est
effectivement les lundis sont partis des
16000 le sac de 50 kg à 20000
aujourd'hui et dans certaines boutiques
21000 et ce qui n'est pas quelque chose
qui arrange le sait les consommateurs et
donc c'est une situation inquiétante est
préoccupante pour tout le pays et
nous exhortons davantage gouvernement à
encourager la production locale
produire localement une ambition devenu
ici plus que jamais urgente sur ce site
de 12 hectares au nord de libreville une
plantation d'aubergines de bananes et de
piment des dizaines de jeunes comme
albert apprennent depuis plusieurs mois
à devenir des entrepreneurs agricoles
une formation qui mise sur le retour à
la terre pour booster la production
locale aujourd'hui je me suis rendu
compte que notre pays le gabon dépend
énormément de l'extérieur nous sommes
plus consommateurs qu'aux producteurs
alors aujourd'hui l'agriculture mais
permet moi aujourd'hui de motos suffire
un peu plus loin sous son hangar brice
anime une session dédiée aux engrais
jusqu'ici ces intrants étaient importés
de russie de biélorussie ou d'ukraine
premiers exportateurs d'engrais azotés
vers le continent mais avec la guerre en
cours ces agriculteurs en herbe doivent
s'adapter en privilégiant des engrais
biologiques locaux à base de compost à
devient hyper compliqué pour nous d'où
nos sens en train de rentrer dans la
phase la création de la composition du
concours parce qu'on se rencontre
aujourd'hui s'il faut prenait l'appel à
l'agriculture bio il faut utiliser nos
matières premières ce retour à la terre
passe
un changement de mentalité par des
formations adéquates pour pouvoir
devenir des potentiels entrepreneurs au
gabon ce retour à la terre a déjà permis
de former des milliers de jeunes
apprenants agricole mais le pays
consacre toujours moins d'un pour cent
du budget de l'état au développement
agricole d'après les nations unies
plus que quelques semaines avant qu'une
partie des soldats français de barkan et
les européens de l'opération takouba
quitte le mali et nous rejoigne l'ue
niger le 15 mai dernier la junte au
pouvoir à bamako a officialisé son
retrait du g5 sel et il y a deux jours
le président nigérien déclaré la mort de
l'organisation aux questions la
correspondante d'harold girard à niamey
le président nigérien mohamed bazoum
sait qu'il doit encore affirmé son
besoin de soutien depuis le début de
l'année 2022 le niger subit une pression
sécuritaire hors norme principalement à
cause de la dégradation de la situation
sécuritaire justement au mali voisin un
voisin qui s'isole de plus en plus et
qui laissent de plus en plus de
possibilités d'expansion aux groupes
armés terroristes qui opèrent sur son
sol il y a deux jours le chef de l'état
nigérien l'a finalement concédé le côté
malien de la frontière entre le mali et
le niger et ce sont ces mots sous la
coupe de l'état islamique au grand
sahara c'est la première fois qu'ils
l'affirment aussi clairement à cela
s'ajoute la dégradation de la situation
sécuritaire cette fois ci du côté des
zones nigérienne les plus proches du
burkina faso hier encore des sources
locales et des sources sécuritaires nous
rapporte une attaque de groupes
terroristes contre trois bus de
transport civil pas de bilan officiel
pour l'instant les autorités nigériennes
se tournent donc vers leurs partenaires
européens qui tarde à déclarer avec
précision la nature de l'aide et de
l'assistance militaire qu'il compte
offrir à l'état nigérien mohamed bazoum
est donc dans une position délicate
alors qu'il y a quelques semaines de
cela son assemblée nationale
lui a donné l'aval la légitimité
populaire d'installer plus de forces
militaires étrangères sur son territoire
place à la culture à présent ce soir on
reçoit un artiste camerounais singulier
un unificateur des genres musicaux et
artistiques il a fait avec le groupe
macase les belles heures du bantou
groove un savant mélange de jazz de soul
avec des rythmes africains depuis
quelques années il poursuit sa quête
personnelle et explore d'autres chemins
artistiques et ce soir il nous présente
sa carte blanche au musée du quai branly
à paris où il va présenter les
merveilles du ton pays le cameroun lic
bassi merci d'être dans le journal de
l'afrique avec nous merci pour
l'invitation mais alors un petit mot
avant de commencer évidemment un petit
mot de l'actualité que vous inspire
l'actualité au cameroun ironiquement
aujourd'hui le 20 mai c'est censé
marquer l'unité du pays et on a
l'impression que le pays n'a jamais été
aussi divisés ouais en fait je pense que
ce jour ses dadas n'a de sens que si
elle résonne comme une cloche qui
appelle à la
vivre ensemble et à la réunification
réel de ce cet espace que j'appelle mon
pays et que parfois j'ai du mal à peine
mon pays basque un pays se pense un pays
ont fait se construit avec un paradigme
avec un récit national avec un
imaginaire commun et c'est pas le cas
c'est à dire là on essaie de survivre
dans cet espace qui a été créée et
auquel on a donné un nom et nous voilà
on laissait duffy survivre tant bien que
mal dans cet espace et d'air c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense que ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui devait arriver
puisque nous on a nous a été on a été
éduqué nous les francophones à
considérer les camerounais lui de la
partie anglophone comme des sceaux
cameron est donc si c'est à aujourd'hui
se leva mais aujourd'hui ne raisonne pas
comme une urgence à la réconciliation je
trouve que c'est dans cette date à mes
yeux n'a aucun sens c'est dommage et
alors parlons à présent de vous vous
êtes un artiste multiple leni née à
yaoundé
j'ai commencé avec ce groupe très
remarqué la case vous faites du band
tout groupe puis vous lancer seul il ya
plusieurs exploration artistique on va
dire il ya mieux premier roman très
remarqué et on se demande finalement
calé j'ai envie de dire votre cohérence
votre ligne directrice artistique
malindi presse artistique est tout
simplement l'histoire de mon pays de mon
continent que j'essaie de raconter à
travers le roman à travers la musique
aujourd'hui à travers le cinéma parce
que moi qui suis né au cameroun qui
grandi là bas et qui vit quelques depuis
quelques années en france en fait je me
suis rendu compte que j'appartenais à un
continent est un pays incroyable qui
malheureusement vit dans des conditions
encore aujourd'hui où des gens de la
population la population et les gens de
ma génération
ont du mal à survivre et tout cela par
tout simplement d'une construction qui
nous a été légué et dans laquelle on a
ici on essaie de suivre iv - à travers
mon art tout ce que j'essaie de faire
c'est tout simplement de rappeler
l'urgence de déconstruire et d'installer
un paradigme qui est le nôtre et à
travers cela je pense que ce continent
wass les faits de manière lumineuse et
alors justement je propose un petit
extrait de 1958 votre dernier album un
an déjà et pour juste savoir qu'est ce
que c'est blick bassy qui on en reparle
après
[Musique]
ouais
ouais nous
ouais ça c'est un extrait de 1958 deux
derniers albums qui est absolument
magnifique
beaucoup merci à vous surtout de l'avoir
fait de l'avoir proposé est alors
passons à à l'artiste celui qui présente
cette carte blanche au quai branly donc
ça commence demain on il va y avoir des
concerts installations conférence
création même inédite parlez nous de
cette carte blanche mais en fait j'ai le
musée du quai branly m'a offert une
carte blanche à travers laquelle
j'essaie de simplement de mettre en
lumière comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le récit de mon continent celui
qui m'anime de russie
de quelqu'un qui est né dans un
continent magnifique et
qui essaye chaque jour de le rappeler à
ses
compères et donc à travers cette carte
blanche j'ai proposé plusieurs choses
notamment court métrage qui raconte
l'histoire des berceuses et ce que
j'essaie d'expliquer à travers c'est ce
film c'est tout simplement de dire que
les berceuses en fait évolué selon la
place de la femme dans une société
patriarcale dans laquelle on vit
aujourd'hui à côté j'ai proposé aussi un
une espèce de pièces théâtrales avec
l'excellent emile abossolo qui va
interviewer des instruments qui ne sont
jamais sortis du parc du musée du quai
branly dans que ce sera leur première
fois de sortir et de raconter s'ils
veulent bien au journalisme il a besoin
qui va faire le journaliste leur vie
dans dans ce parc là et ensuite j'ai un
spectacle
de danse qui est porté par quatre
superbes danseuses en fait qui raconte
l'histoire d'une reine qui s'appelle
mois nyaga et qui en 1885 lorsque bismes
a décidé de céder scinder l'afrique en
différents morceaux va se lever et va
décider de résister contre toute forme
d'impérialisme de colonisation à travers
cinq armées de danseuses qui auront pour
objectif pas de se battre contre les les
les impérialismes est tout simplement
amener leurs peuples et leurs
populations à se reconnecter à leurs
traditions à leurs racines parce que
lorsqu'on est mentalement instable on ne
laisse place à aucune forme de
colonisation
j'imagine qu'il ya un prochain album qui
va arriver bientôt en tout cas nous on
attend c'est pourquoi le prochain album
le prochain album il arrive il sera en
je suis déçu je travaille déjà depuis
les traites c'est très très très très
avancé et il sera là je pense l'année
prochaine mais juste pour apprendre
parler ce prochain album je voulais dire
dans cette carte blanche qui a également
demain
une super soirée avec trois jeunes
chanteuses de la scène nouvelle scène
féminine africaine qui sont point d'eau
car s photo amy est rigolo et à et donc
voilà j'ai vite bien ce parisien vers
des coutumes à venir découvrir vous
reviendrez pour nous en parler merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur le plateau du
journal l'afrique sur france 24 et c'est
avec nous l'actualité continue on se
quitte en musique avec un peu
d'obligations
[Musique]